Welcome back to Quantum Computing in Practice. This is episode 6. Today we're going to focus on one of my favorite
applications of quantum computers, simulating nature. In this episode, we are going to discuss the steps required
to do this for any sort of quantum dynamics problem, which is the problem of finding how the description of a
quantum system changes with time. We'll do this at a high level first and then look into a specific example and walk
through it in detail. namely the 2023 IBM experiment that demonstrated quantum utility. For some quick motivation at
the start, one of the most famous stories that those of us in the field of quantum computing tell again and again,
the story of Richard Fineman giving a lecture at Caltech in 1959 and basically
providing motivation for the entire field for decades to come. The speech was called there's plenty of room at the
bottom. a funny title, but the basic idea was that he was claiming there was still so much rich physics to be
discovered at the microscopic level.
Now, that specific talk wasn't given much heed until the 80s when technology had developed quite a bit. And Feman
also clarified and refined his message over time. He returned to Caltech in the 80s and presented another paper called
simulating nature with computers where he specifically said he wanted to talk about the possibility that there is to
be an exact simulation that the computer will do exactly the same as nature.
essentially being able to get rid of crude approximations of what goes on at the atomic scale and replace them with
computers that understand and harness quantum physics to not just simulate what nature is doing, but emulate it.
Now, recall this timeline graphic I showed in a previous episode. At one end, we had problems that were easy to
solve and will not require any sort of speed up quantum could offer. But at the other end, we have problems that are
very hard and need fault tolerant quantum machines which we don't yet have.
Luckily, we believe that there are quite a few simulation problems that lie here in the middle, which is the region that
we can currently work in. And there are lots of reasons to be excited and intrigued by this prospect because the
simulation of nature is the basis for a lot of exciting application areas. just to name a few. If we could better
simulate nature, we could accelerate the discovery of new materials, create better pharmaceuticals and medicine, or
even explore new physics underlying particle physics or cosmology. But before you or I or anyone can attempt to
apply quantum computing to these exciting areas for now, they will need to understand the basic steps in a
typical simulationbased workflow.
First, you'll want to identify a quantum system of interest. This will inform you about the Hamiltonian governing its time
evolution and a meaningful description of its starting properties or its state.
Then you'll need to find an appropriate method to implement the time evolution of this state. With these ingredients
sorted out, the next steps involve carrying out the actual experiment.
These generally involve optimizing the quantum circuit implementation of the time evolution algorithm, executing the
circuit or circuits on quantum hardware and post-processing the results. So we
can name the basic steps involved in a simulation experiment as follows.
Identifying the system Hamiltonian, Hamiltonian encoding, state preparation, state evolution,
circuit optimization, circuit execution, and post-processing.
But these are quite detailed steps. Remember that the four stages of the Qiskit patterns framework, which helps
us understand how to implement a routine in Kiskit are mapping, circuit optimization, circuit execution, and
post-processing. So these four first steps here are actually all included under the umbrella of mapping and that's
why we spent an entire episode on this first stage and if you missed that please go back and watch the previous episode.
Now let's first walk through what these steps even mean before we dive into any coding. So the first basic thing we need
to do to perform a simulation experiment is to identify the Hamiltonian that describes the system. Sometimes well
often these are wellnown other times we have to put it together from understanding the energy contributions
of the small subsets of the full system like so where hi is the Hamiltonian acting on one of the n subsystems of h.
We will also need to note if the system consists of firmians or bzons if we are dealing with elementary particles. Next,
we need to encode the Hamiltonian and translate it into terms quantum computers can understand. Often times,
these Hamiltonians will be made up of elementary particles or spin systems. If we were simulating firmians or bzons, we
will need to choose an encoding transformation like the Jordan Wigner or Bravi Katev. These transformations will
tell us how to translate the definition of the Hamiltonian written in terms of the original components. the firmians or
bzzons into pi operators which are easily converted into gates on a quantum computer. For example, the Jordan winger
transformation defined here gives a mapping from firmian operators to poly operators. If we are already dealing
with spin 1/2 systems which are very common then we're good to go aside from any possible normalization coefficients
and we don't need to use an encoding scheme. Having encoded the desired Hamiltonian into the quantum computer's
gate set, the next crucial step is to determine the appropriate initial quantum state from which to begin our
simulation. This state should ideally reflect some physical meaning or configuration of the
system under study. For example, if we're interested in exploring the ground state energy of a molecule, we might
start with a heartry faul approximation or another easily preparable ons that has significant overlap with the true
ground state. The choice of initial ground state affects not only the convergence of variational algorithms
like VQE the variational quantum solver but also the accuracy and efficiency of
time evolution or sampling in the quantum phase estimation. In essence, the initial state serves as the
launching point for the computation setting the stage for extracting useful observables about the quantum system
that we're modeling. the preparation of an arbitrary n cubit state where ci are the computational basis states and ai is